في التطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان وفد يضم وين نائبه
وزير الخارجيه ومسؤولين من مجلس الامن
القومي ووزاره الدفاع زار العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيابل لقاء الرئيس
بولوتبيرنسكي وعدد من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين وذكرت الخارجيه في بيان ان
الوفد جدد واشنطن الثابته تجاه كيف ضد
العدوان الروسي غير المبرر
كما زار المدير العام لوكاله الطاقه
الذريه رافاييل روسي محطه النوويه في
مقاطعه ميكو لايف جنوبي اوكرانيا وقال
روسي ان زيارته تهدف لضمان السلامه والامن
النوويين وان الوكاله ستكون حاضره بشكل
دائم في جميع محطات الطاقه الاوكرانيه ومن
المتوقع ان يبحث روسي مع المسؤولين
الاخرانيين ان شاء الله
جنوب البلاد